طيب نحو ملياريه الشخص بيكون الحاء اسيا
يحتفلون بعام الارنب حدثنا اكثر عن هذا
الطقس الصيني همم تاريخه وثقافته يعني هل
هو نفهم اكثر منك
العام الصيني قصه اسطوريه معروفه عند
الناس كثيرين بعطيكم القصه مبسطه يقولون
كان في قديم الزمان همم قبل بدايه راس
السنه الصينيه
طلع لهم وحش وحش اسطوري ينفث النار اسمها
نيام وهذا الوحش شو كان يسوي كان يقتل
الحيوانات والناس ويعمل فوضه في القرى
فالناس مو عارفين شو يسوون ضد على الوحش
فاكتشفه ان هذا الوحش يخاف من اللي هو
الاحمر ويخاف من اصوات العاليه ويخاف من
النور
[موسيقى]
راس السنه قاموا يلعبون العاب الناريه
ويعلقون اللوحات الحمراء والفوانيس الحمر
شو حتى يخوفون الوحش يعني ومن هنا بدات
اسطوره او قصه راس السنه الحيوانات
لكل سنه
والل همم
الدائره دائره السنه او قصدي
الكلندر عباره عن 12 سنه
فكل السنه ترمز له حيوان معين وكل حيوان
له صفات معينه الارنب معروف ان السريع
ويقولون انه يفكر ببطء بحيث انه ياخذ
القرار الصحيح فالارنب يعتبر من السنوات
التي انتجها الصينيون سكان اسيا
همم في راس السنه همم من اهم المهرجانات
اللي عندهم او همم احتفال براس السنه فكل
الصينيين لازم يتجمعون مع بعض في راس
السنه حتى لو كانوا مو موجودين في قصدي في
الدول المختلفه يتجمعون في الدوله
اجتماع العائله هذا الشيء ضروري عند
الصينيين واا طبعا الصينيين لازم ياكلون
على طاوله مدوره
طاوله مدوره بحيث انه اذا حاطه والاكل
ولفه والطاولق الواحد يقدر يوصل لاي اكله
والغريب الصينيين عنده ابعاده شبيهه
بالعرب هو المسلمين العيديه
عندهم ظرف احمر اسمه حم يعني احمر او يعني
الظرف
فالكبار شو يسوون يحطونه فلوس في همم
الظرف يوزعون على الاطفال مثل العيديه
وهذا يعتبر للجلب الحظ بس انا سنوات
القادمه